(intense music)
- Now, why did I just
put my phone on the roof?
This video is all about
conducting an experiment
and I need to take every precaution.
I'm just very, very, very convinced
that TikTok is spying on me.
(tense music)
You're probably picking up on
a lot of chaotic energy
right now, and that's fair.
And it's because I'm pretty sure TikTok
has been spying on me,
I just have yet to catch TikTok
in the act of spying on me.
For the next week, I
am going to be staging
fake conversations around my phone
in order to bait TikTok into serving me
a targeted video on my For You page.
Should I be having
these fake conversations
while I'm using TikTok?
Should I be having these conversations
while TikTok is open in the background
but I'm using a different app?
Should I be having these conversations
while my phone is just sitting there?
So in the name of science
and to just check all the boxes,
we're gonna do all three.
While I am using TikTok, the app itself,
I will be planting the
code word French toast.
While I'm using my phone
but TikTok is running in the background,
I will be planting the code word umbrella.
And finally, while keeping my
phone in a tight radius of me,
I will be planting the code word walrus.
Here we go.
I want to see either French
toast, umbrella, walrus,
or God help us, all three.
I have just been absolutely
craving French toast lately.
I don't know what they put in it,
if it was like vanilla extract.
Which do you think is better,
French toast or pancakes?
- [Woman] Definitely French toast.
- I agree!
All right, so you know,
just scrolling around Twitter, YouTube.
I don't remember if it's
gonna rain tomorrow,
do you know if I'm gonna need an umbrella?
Like what makes a good umbrella?
I feel like all the umbrellas
I get are so crappy.
Have you ever seen a walrus in person?
- [Woman] Definitely not.
- You've never seen a walrus?
Walruses are the ones with the huge tusks
and the little goatee, right?
All righty, it is the end of day one.
We have to check TikTok
for French toast, umbrella, and walrus.
Here we go.
(tense music)
There was something that resembled
something similar to French toast
and I almost had a heart attack.
(tense music)
I think we've given the For
You page a fair shot tonight.
On to day two.
(intense music)
Before we get into day two,
I wanted to make sure I mentioned
that anytime you see this shot,
anytime we're having this conversation,
my phone is on lockdown.
Just last week I was having a conversation
about a very specific street food,
and then days later I got
a TikTok on my For You page
of that exact street food.
I'm going to share one more example
that is a little embarrassing.
In conversation with my
wife around our apartment,
I will refer to my stomach as my pooch.
I'm sharing this because a few
days ago, on my For You page,
I get a TikTok, how to get
rid of your belly pooch.
That's why I'm doing this experiment.
I know it's happening,
I just need to catch TikTok
in the act of listening to me.
I think the key to a good
French toast is a good bread.
I could really go for some French toast.
Oh man, I really need an umbrella,
all I've got is my coat.
That's not gonna cut it.
I need an umbrella, it's raining.
I would love to just curl up on the couch
with a nice big walrus.
I bet a walrus would love this weather.
They're in the ocean, they're
in the water all the time.
A little rain never hurt a walrus.
We're at the very end of day two,
gonna look at TikTok one
more time before bed.
(tense music)
Day two of the experiment, no luck.
(intense music)
Even though this experiment is for a week,
I really thought we were
gonna be somewhere by now.
Overall, it's way more draining
than I thought it would be
of what can I say around my phone?
What can I say on camera?
Did I say the wrong thing into the phone?
Am I saying the right
thing into the camera?
I just need to see something.
Day number three of doing
nothing out of the ordinary,
just talking about my
favorite things out loud
like I always do, right?
I really wish I just had someone tell me
how to make French toast.
If anyone's listening,
can you show me how to make French toast?
To anyone who's listening who thinks
I'm running out of ways
to talk about umbrellas.
(scoffing)
No way, I could talk
about umbrellas all day.
I just wish I could look at umbrellas.
The only thing that would
make this day better
is if I just saw some umbrellas.
Reply in the comments
with your number one favorite sea mammal.
I don't know if a walrus is a sea mammal.
If I'm wrong, I want someone to correct me
by showing me a walrus.
May I have a walrus, please?
May I please have a walrus?
We're gonna check TikTok,
see what's going on.
(tense music)
I feel like I'm going insane,
because I just got a TikTok
about how to replace a light on a ceiling.
Okay?
And I was at the hardware store yesterday
getting the tools to replace
the light on the ceiling.
Help me.
(intense music)
(laughing) Where do I start?
In the midst of shooting this video,
my wife gets a TikTok about
finding a dress for a wedding.
I swear on my life,
days before we were in a vintage store
talking about dresses for weddings.
And at the rate things are going,
I think we have to switch up the words.
We gotta keep TikTok on its toes.
While using TikTok, candle.
While using other apps, eggplant.
While my phone is nearby, scorpion.
New words.
(tense music)
Every time I look around this bathroom
I feel like I need a candle.
I'm also not sure on scent.
Like is this a eucalyptus vibe in here?
I don't want to be cocky, but
I've got a nose for candles.
I've never really picked a bad candle.
If there's one vegetable
I would love to master,
it's the eggplant.
When I go to the store, I don't even know
if I know how to tell a good
eggplant from a bad eggplant.
Normally I am not that
bothered by insects,
but for some reason, scorpions
just don't sit well with me.
It's the poison.
It's the pincers.
I wonder if I should start manifesting
a scorpion encounter just
to see what I'm made of.
Time to check TikTok.
(tense music)
(sighing) Come on.
(intense music)
I'm not even frustrated,
at this point I'm just mad.
But that's okay, we gotta keep it moving.
We need three new words.
While I'm using TikTok, owl.
While I'm using other apps, baseball.
While the phone is nearby, soup.
Let's just get back to it.
(tense music)
Who.
(laughing)
That's the sound of one of
my favorite birds, the owl.
It's a shame that animals are nocturnal
because I would love to see
owls more during the day,
if possible.
Keep your eyes peeled for
the owls in the trees.
Maybe they're here, maybe they're not.
Let's be honest, t's a
beautiful day for baseball.
Anybody think I should just stop
some random person on the sidewalk
and ask if they wanna
play baseball with me,
ask if they wanna have a catch?
Is baseball one of those sports
I'm just supposed to like?
Some soup on a warm day.
I guess there's cold soup,
is that what gazpacho is?
All this walking, worked
up quite an appetite.
A big bowl of soup should
help take care of that.
Is gazpacho a soup even though it's cold?
Hunting for soup, hunting for soup.
Phew, here we go.
(tense music)
Yes!
Are you (beep) kidding me?
(beep)
Okay, I think we got it.
That's an owl baby!
Okay.
What does this mean?
While I was using the TikTok app,
there were so many times where it happened
but I wasn't able to document it
and then I finally just
slammed it into TikTok.
I don't know, I don't know.
(sighing)
As satisfying as it was to see that owl,
can I definitively say the
TikTok was listening to me
and showed me an owl?
Maybe.
Something I thought about
while doing this experiment,
some of the targeted TikToks
I got were pretty big.
So maybe it's TikTok
just funneling viral videos
through their algorithm.
But then other TikToks
that were about things
I was speaking about
that were on the small side,
it really makes my brain hurt
in terms of how that lands up in my eyes.
Will I be going back on TikTok
for hours on end, day after day?
I'm gonna try not to.
Thank you for showing
me what I wanted to see,
but also not thank you for listening to me
when I don't want you
to be listening to me.
(tense music)